[Music]
good evening and thank you so much for
joining us tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis we start tonight with
two developing stories in different
parts of the valley
metro police piecing together two deadly
shootings one on hacienda near tropicana
and decatur
the other on tropicana not too far from
the u.s 95.
we're told these are not related let's
go live now to that second scene madison
kimbrough is standing by with an update
on both cases for us madison
yes sasha so two homicides tonight but
let's first start with the one right
here on the 4400 block
of bennett drive take a look at the
video that we shot earlier where you can
see the
scene it was reported that a white man
in his 70s
was shot and beaten while outside of his
home around six tonight
the suspect is described as a black man
but that's all we know at this time the
suspect fled the scene
on foot now as for the homicide on wes
hacienda
this is what we know so far a teenage
boy is dead
this all stemming from an altercation
involving the teenage boy's sister and
abusive
boyfriend we are told the sister's
mother and brother
came to the boyfriend's apartment and
got into some sort of altercation with
him
the boyfriend then pulled out a gun
shooting the brother
and killing him the boyfriend then fled
in his vehicle
or a vehicle from the scene so at this
point we have not spoken with him we
urge him to turn himself in so we can
speak with him
if he's watching please you can just
reach out call 3-1-1
because we would like to get his version
of the event
of course if you know anything about
either of these cases police encourage
you to call crime stoppers you can
remain anonymous
we will of course keep you updated right
here on channel 8
about both of these stories as more
information becomes available
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now